how do you rebuild after covid when you
can't get the workers to do the job
it's a central question for the economy
and one they're grappling with on the
ground on this site in wooleton in
nottingham
they're building 16 homes here but
securing the right trades people at the
right time is a challenge one that's
getting more expensive
the sector has struggled for a long
period of time now with uh with the
skill shortage it's nothing new
um it's been there for a number of years
but you know on the back of everything
that's happened with covid and with
brexit we seem to have
created a real sort of situation that
isn't improving
with disrupted supply chains struggling
to meet resurgent demand the labor
market is in uncharted territory
the combination of low unemployment and
record vacancies more than 1.3 million
unfilled jobs in the economy ought to be
good news for workers forcing employers
to pay them more to attract talent and
wages are rising for many problem is
they're not rising fast enough to keep
up with inflation and the cost of living
the latest figures show real wages
judged against the headline rate of
consumer price inflation have fallen
faster and further than at any time in
two decades to minus 4.5 per cent
the trent bridge the cricket was
inflation proof tickets were free
ensuring a full house to watch england
win and a busy day for staff at the
larwood and vos pub hospitality has
offered some of the steepest pay rises
of any sector but it can still be a
struggle
we've not just followed the rises we
perhaps stayed ahead of them in some
cases we're paying people more
because i think it's the right thing to
do but
that then has to be followed with price
rises for everything that we sell
so you know the price of a pint is
probably more than it's ever been food
prices are going up so
you know it's a tough little equilibrium
the workforce is also missing almost
half a million people who can't or don't
want to work some of them because
postcovid priorities have
changed without them there may be no
easy economic wins paul kelsey's sky
news in nottingham